a pesar de que la semana pasada del
presidente Joe biden haya calificado
como insignificante los documentos
encontrados en su residencia y oficina
privada en Washington esta tercera Ronda
de material confidencial encontrado ha
despertado nuevos cuestionamientos sobre
el manejo de la información confidencial
por parte del presidente sobre todo
después de que en repetidas ocasiones la
Casa Blanca haya dicho que está
cooperando con el departamento de
Justicia este viernes se encontraron más
documentos clasificados en la residencia
de Joe biden en Delaware tras una
búsqueda acordada entre el FBI y la casa
blanca que según los abogados de biden
demuestran que el presidente está
cooperando para tratar de resolver el
asunto cuanto antes en esta ocasión se
encontraron concretamente y fue
información confidencial de cuando era
senador y hasta notas escritas a mano
cuando era vicepresidente medios
nacionales están cuestionando porque si
está cooperando con la justicia y el
allanamiento fue este viernes apenas se
conoció la noticia el sábado además
muchos están diciendo que esto le resta
legitimidad moral al partido demócrata y
al presidente para criticar a Trump y a
los republicanos de eventual corrupción